welcome the star of The Matrix Keanu
Reeves
for over 100 years movies have taught us
who we are where we are and who we
aspire to be in that regard the most
effective teachers have been the special
effects wizards who can make any wish
come true
look at these nominees for achievement
in visual effects
a gym rival Jolla tearin Randall William
cook and Alex funky used a computer
motion capture system to create a split
personality character of golem and
Smeagol in the Lord of the Rings the two
towers not only could he spin a web but
spider-man could practically fly thanks
to the sweeping visual effects created
by nominees John Dykstra Scott Stockton
anthony llama llanera
and John Fraser and over in a galaxy far
far away created by George Lucas
nominees Rob Coleman Pablo Hellman John
Knoll and Ben snow Hilton knew all
digital universe for Star Wars Episode
two attack of the clones and the Oscar
goes to gymraeg El Cholo Terry random
William cook and Alex funky for the Lord
of the Rings the Q Tower
the first Academy Award for Joe latarian
funky and the second for Jim Rygel and
William Randall cook they both won
Oscars in 2001 for the Lord of the Rings
the Fellowship of the Ring
Thank You Academy thank you Peter
Jackson for directing three pieces of
cinematic history and allowing us to be
involved in it Fran Walsh Barry Osborne
newline Marco deskey Lauren Ricci Dean
right Libby hazel my family tree
caesarian Jackson and wet a digital in
Wellington New Zealand thank you all for
this amazing Award and thanks especially
to the incredible people at what a
digital and wet workshop will help make
this all possible and thanks out being
Sofia especially our amazing animation
department
the 75th and
cata me Awards on ABC